JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
One of the things you've been
learning about in lecture
is how to solve some
max-min problems.
How to find the maximum
or minimum of a given
function given some constraints
and figure out where it reaches
its largest or smallest value.
So here I have a particular
example of such a problem.
So we're going to
build a cardboard box.
And our cardboard box has to
meet the following criteria.
So its volume has to be 3 units.
The front and back
of the cardboard box
are going to be made just of
single-thickness cardboard.
But the two sides,
the left and right,
are going to be
made double-thick.
And the bottom is going
to be made triple-thick.
We're not going to
have a top, it's
just going to be an open box.
So it's going to have five
sides: two of single thickness,
two of double thickness,
and with the bottom
of triple thickness.
So, the question is--
there are, you know,
a lot of different shapes of
box with total volume 3 units.
So the question is what
dimensions should this box
have so that we use the minimum
amount of cardboard possible?
All right?
So we want the
dimensions of the box
that use the least
total amount cardboard.
So why don't you pause the
video, work on that for awhile,
come back, and we can
work on it together
I hope you had some fun
puzzling this one out.
Let's have a go at it.
So to start, I think
I'd just like to draw
a little picture of a box.
So here's my cardboard box.
Its top is going
to be open, say.
So let's give it--
we want to figure out
what its dimensions
should be in order
to minimize some expression,
so let's give them names.
Right?
So I think a natural
thing to call
them is we can call
one of them x and one
of them y and the height z.
There.
So if we give the box these
dimensions, x, y, and z,
we need to ask, well first
of all, what is its volume?
And second of all, how
much cardboard is used?
And as long as we
can keep the volume
equal to 3, what's the least
amount of cardboard we can use?
So the volume of this box is
just x*y*z and that has to be
3.
So we know x*y*z is equal to
the volume, which is equal to 3.
So we have a constraint
on x, y, and z here.
And the thing that
we want to optimize--
that we want to
find a minimum for--
is the total amount
of cardboard used.
So let's talk about how
much cardboard is used.
So the bottom of the
box is triple-thick.
So its area is x times y.
So the total amount of
cardboard used is 3x*y.
Now, the front and back of
the box are single thickness.
And they have area x*y, but
there-- sorry, not x*y, x*z,
right?
This height is z,
so it's x times z--
and there are two of them.
So we have x*z total cardboard
in front and x*z total
cardboard in back.
Oh, I guess this has another
segment there in back
because it's an open box.
So x*z and x*z.
So that's 2x*z coming
from the front and back.
And from the two sides,
well each side has area y*z.
There are two of them
and they're double-thick.
So that contributes 4y*z to the
total amount of cardboard used.
So this is the total
amount of cardboard used.
And we know x*y*z is equal to 3.
So we want to
minimize this, but we
want to minimize
this taking this
into account, taking this
restriction on the volume
into account.
So what we can do
is you can realize
that we can just eliminate
one of these variables.
Right?
We can say z is
equal to 3 over x*y.
That always has to be true.
And if we make that
substitution in here,
then we'll be able to minimize
this expression without regard
to any constraint anymore.
So from x*y*z equals 3, we
have z equals 3 over x*y.
So we want to minimize what
we get when we plug z equals 3
over x*y into here.
So that's 3x*y, plus-- well, 2x
times 3 over x*y is 6-- over y,
plus-- and 4y times 3
over x*y is 12-- over x.
And one other thing I guess we
haven't mentioned explicitly
is that this is a physical box.
It has actual dimensions,
so its dimensions have
to be, you know--
they're lengths,
they have to be
positive numbers.
So we want for x to be
positive and we want for y
to be positive numbers.
OK.
So now we've got this function.
And there aren't-- x
and y can be anything,
any value of x and y we choose.
This describes the
amount of cardboard
used in a box with
those dimensions
on its base that has volume 3.
All right?
So we want to minimize that.
So now we've finally got to
the point of our calculus.
Let's call this function--
let's give it a name
like, I don't know-- f of x, y.
So we want to find the
global minimum of f.
We want to find the absolute
least amount of cardboard
that we can use.
So there are several
possibilities
for where a global
minimum can occur.
It can occur on some critical
point of the function,
or it can occur on the
boundary of the region
where the function is defined.
And in this case, that
includes the possibility
that it can occur as x or y
or both go off to infinity.
All right?
So we have to look at
those possibilities.
In particular, we have to
look at the critical points.
That's one of the possibilities.
So the critical points of f.
So we need to find out
what those points are.
So in order to find the critical
points, well what do we do?
We do the usual thing.
We look at its
partial derivatives.
So we need the first
and second-- or sorry--
the first partial derivatives
with respect to x and y,
we need both of them
to be equal to 0.
So we need f_x equals
0, and f_y equals 0.
OK, so let's write down
what that means over here.
So what is f_x?
Well, we just take the partials.
So it's 3y-- plus we take the
partial of 6y with respect
to x and we get 0, and we
take the partial of 12 over x
with respect to x-- and we
get minus 12 over x squared.
So that's f_x, and we need
that to be equal to 0.
And f_y is equal to 3x
minus 6 over y squared,
and we also need that
to be equal to 0.
So if we solve this first
equation, for example,
we can solve it for
y in terms of x.
And that tells me
that y is equal to--
I need-- let's see-- 12
over x squared divided by 3,
so that's 4 over x squared.
Now I can plug this 4 over
x squared in down here,
and so I get 3x minus 6.
Well, 6 divided by 4 divided
by x squared quantity
squared is 6 times x
squared over 4 squared.
That has to be equal to 0.
And I can-- let's see--
I can rewrite this.
Maybe I'll divide
through by 3 as
that 3 isn't going to matter.
So it's x minus-- so then
I'll be left with 2 times x
to the fourth over 16, so
that's-- x to the fourth over 8
equals 0.
And you can see in this equation
that either x is equal to 0,
or we can divide by x and
then we get x cubed equals 8.
So x equals 0 or
x cubed equals 8.
The only solution is x equals 2.
Now, it's easy to see
that we can't have
a box with x equal to 0, right?
Our function is not actually
defined at x equals 0 over
here, you'll see, right.
Our function had
a 12 over x in it,
so we can't have x equal to 0.
So that's not going
to be a critical point
of this function.
x equals 0 isn't
going to lead to a
critical point, so, OK,
so our only critical
points are going
to happen when x is equal to 2.
And when x is equal to
2, we can go back up here
and we see that y
was equal to 4 over x
squared at our critical points.
So the only critical
point is (2, 1).
OK.
So that's our critical point.
So now, we want
to think about is
this point going to be a
maximum or a minimum or what?
And where is the global
minimum of this function
going to occur?
So remember that the global
minimum of this function
can occur either on the critical
points or on the boundary
or at a point where x or
y is going to infinity--
in the limit, I guess I mean.
So lets go back here and take
a look at our function here.
So we can see from the
expression for this function
that if x and y are going to
infinity, this is no good.
This part is going
to go to infinity.
3x*y is going to go to infinity,
and these are going to be
positive, so f is going
to go to infinity.
OK, so as the dimensions of
our box get very, very large,
the total amount of cardboard
used becomes infinite.
Also, if x or y gets
closer and closer
to 0-- that's at
the boundary-- well,
if x gets closer
and closer to 0,
than 12 over x gets closer
and closer to infinity.
And if y gets closer and
closer to 0, then 6 over y
gets closer and
closer to infinity.
And again, all these
terms are going
to be positive because x
and y have to be positive.
So in those limiting cases,
the function f of x, y
gets infinitely large.
So along the boundary and
as x and y go to infinity,
this function blows up.
It gets very, very big.
So that means the only place
it could have a global-- so it
has a global minimum-- the only
place that global minimum can
be is at a critical point.
And we saw, if we
walk back over here
again, that the only critical
point is the point (2, 1).
All right?
So that means this point
has to be a global minimum
for the function.
Now, you might,
out of curiosity,
you might ask how much cardboard
are we actually talking
about in that case?
Since that's really
the one part--
I guess it wasn't really
part of the question,
but it's an interesting
thing to ask.
So in this case, we use
f of 2, 1 equals-- well,
let's see-- so that's 6 plus 6
plus 6 equals 18 units squared
of cardboard.
Now, I guess one
thing you might notice
is we didn't use the second
derivative test here.
And the question
is why-- I mean,
we concluded it was a global
maximum without ever using
the second derivative test.
Sorry, global minimum.
Pardon me.
And the second derivative
test is the thing
that tells us whether
things are minimum
or maximum or saddle points.
So why didn't we use it?
Well, the answer is the
second derivative test
tells you whether something
is a local minimum or maximum
or whether it's a saddle point.
So if we had applied the
second derivative test
at this critical point,
what we would have learned
is that this critical
point is a local minimum.
But being a local minimum
isn't enough to guarantee
that it's a global minimum.
Because we could have
on the boundary--
or as x or y goes
to infinity-- we
could have that the function
value get smaller and smaller
without bound.
Now in this case, we showed that
the function doesn't do that.
It gets larger and
larger without bound.
And so that meant that
that minimum point really
is the global minimum.
But the second
derivative test isn't
enough to conclude
that something
is a global minimum on its own.
You really do need that
extra analysis that we did.
I'll end there.